e aí meus amigos e aí galera jornal tudo
com você e acabei de chegar de
fortalecer e aqui na minha casa está com
saudade porque saudade dessa casa de
opel deus que só para ter suas paredes
sujas e salvar esse experimento é cio
agora só come derrota meu bem eu fui só
ponto fácil eu não fui foi nessa casa do
vovô outro lugar então vai dar 5 dia
tanque estava a secar foi omissa cadinho
mais doeu mudança casa pudesse fazer
sexo com ela
a nau
pois é a galera eu tô aqui que eu estou
muito feliz
galera hoje o canal completou 40 milhões
de visualizações ao torcedor do samu que
40 milhões de visualizações dúvidas eu
só vou te dar uma dica de que é 40
milhões de visualizações é isso aqui ó ó
[Música]
kaká sabe que deus 40 milhões de
visualizações vou sei que eu mais amo na
vida
eike gostoso então se você fez parte se
você fez parte disso se você me conta
como foi tudo fez se você fez ou eu
quero que você vê logo aquele light que
lilic e maroto com aquele sinal de fé eu
ajudei e outra coisa podia pagar uma
conta no twitter
temos um número de casos foi primeiro
nos tts e agora não vou mudar outra
hashtag no twitter que é hashtag o inter
são 40 milhões de views também a
descrição do vídeo só copia cola no
twitter me deseja mais vídeos me deseja
mais vi e deseja sexo e drogas que
ouviram homossexual
heitor brincando brincando brincadeira
sexo e droga não e bota hashtag lá e
outra coisa eu cheguei eu cheguei cá
quando cheguei vi as tinha um presente
de uma fã para mim aqui o prazer da já
disse que lula recebeu vou mostrar pra
vocês agora meu amigo aquele short em
que ele aquele malbec uma blusa e ibiza
open para icó
clique aqui negociei e obrigado pelo
presente meu irmão ele presente você
sabe que é feita na guiné é um carro
[Música]
também foi também passou mal também eu
também ganhei muitas coisas sobre ela
também se você quer saber também aqui
sou eu sei que sou eu tô pomar marcou
época um pouco mais com a cabeça
ficar oliveira ps bonequinha que também
por já hoje é o verão da felicidade hoje
a galera como eu acabei de chegar e eu
já vou ter que sair não vou conseguir
falar muito mais coisa aqui então muito
obrigado estou muito feliz pelas 40
milhões de visualizações se você fez
parte disso se você faz parte desse
canal e torce para que ele cresça
clique no gosto e sei comenta aqui em
baixo o que te fez feliz depois dessa
semana santa que eu que me fez a
diferença a semana santa foi ter
completado os 40 milhões que valeu e tal
a etapa que sai da minha casa em deus
que bom